I want to bring you some breaking news  now this a post online from the  Manchester United and Portuguese  footballer Cristiano Ronaldo some sad  news he says as you can see there it is  with our deepest sadness we have to  announce that our baby boy has passed  away it is the greatest pain that any  parents can feel only the birth of our  baby girl gives us the strength to live  this moment with some hope and happiness  the statement goes on we would like to  thank the doctors and nurses for all  their expert care and support we are all  devastated at this loss and we kindly  ask for privacy that this very difficult  time our baby boy you are our Angel we  will always love you that is signed by  Cristiano Ronaldo and his partner there  Georgina  Rodriguez and so the death announced of  their baby boy they believe to be twin  girl has survived so some sad news there  from the Manchester United at football  it will bring you up more on this as we  get it